so you have a lot of tests in front of
you
uh could you maybe explain some of them
absolutely
so there's a few different classes of
tests
that i just have here and there's more
tests there's many more different tests
out in the world too
these are these are one class of tests
these are
uh rapid antigen tests that are just the
most bare bones paper strip tests these
uh are this is the type that i want to
see
produced in the tens of millions every
day it's so simple
you know you don't even need the plastic
cartridge you can just you can just make
uh make the paper strip and you could
have a little
a little tube like this that you know
you just dunk the paper strip into you
don't actually need
the plastic which i'd actually prefer
because if we start making tens of
millions of these this becomes a lot of
waste
so i'd rather not see this kind of waste
be out there and there's a few companies
quiedell
is making a test called the quick view
which is just just this it's uh
they've gotten rid of all the all the
plastic and for people who are just
listening to this we're looking at some
very small
tests that fit in the palm of your hand
and they're basically paper strips
fit into different containers and that's
hence the comment about the plastic
containers
these are just injection molded i think
and uh
you got it they're um you know they can
build them
at high numbers but then they have to
like place them in there appropriately
and all this stuff so it is a
it is a bottleneck or some somewhat of a
bottleneck in manufacturing
the actual bottleneck uh which the
government i think should use the
defense productions act to build up
is the uh there's a nitrocellulose
membrane a laminated membrane on this
that allows uh the the material the this
the the buffer and with the swab mixture
to flow across it
so the way these work they're called
lateral flow tests
and you take a swab you swab the the
front of your nose
you dunk that swab into some buffer and
then you
put a couple drops of that buffer onto
the lateral flow and just like
uh paper if you dip a piece of paper
into a cup of water
though the paper will pull the water up
through capillary action this actually
works very similarly it flows
through somewhat a capillary action
through this nitrocellulose membrane
and there's little antibodies on there
these little proteins that are very
specific in this case for antigens or
proteins of the virus
so these are antibodies similar to how
to the antibodies that our body makes
from our immune system but they're just
printed on these lateral flow tests and
they're printed just like a little
a line so then you you slice these all
up into
individual ones and if there's any virus
on that buffer as it flows across the
antibodies grab that virus
and it creates a little reaction with
some colloids in here that cause it to
turn dark
just like a pregnancy test um one line
means negative it means a control
strip worked and two lines mean positive
means uh
you know but if you get two lines it
just means you have virus there you're
very very likely to have virus there and
so
uh so they're super simple this is it is
the exact same technology as pregnancy
tests
it's uh the technology this particular
one from abbott
this has been used uh for other
infectious diseases
like malaria and and actually a number
of these companies have made malaria
tests that do the exact same thing
so they just co-opted their the same
form factor
and uh and just changed the antibodies
so it picks up
sars kof2 instead of other infections is
it also the abbott one is it also strip
yep yeah this abbott one here is uh
there's the in this case instead of
being put in a plastic sheath it's just
put in a cardboard thing and
literally glued on i mean it's it looks
like nothing you know it's just
it looks like a like i mean it's just
the simplest thing you can you could
imagine the exterior packaging looks
very apple like this nice
it does yeah yeah yeah so it's nice and
it comes in
this is the this is how they're packaged
you know so
and they don't have to you know this
these are coming in individual packages
against
again because they're really considered
individual medical devices
but you could package them in you know
bigger packets and stuff you want to be
careful with humidity so they all have a
little
one of those humidity removing things
and oxygen removing things
um so that's the this is one class these
antigen tests if we could just pause for
a second if it's okay
and uh could you just briefly say what
is an antigen test and what other tests
there are out there like categories of
tests
sure just really quick so the testing
landscape is a little bit complicated
but it's
but i'll break it down there's really
just three major classes of tests
uh we'll start with the first two the
the first two tests are just
looking for the virus or looking for
antibodies
against the virus so we've heard about
serology tests
or maybe some people have heard about it
those are a different kind of test
they're looking to
see has somebody in the past does
somebody have an immune response against
the virus which would indicate that they
were infected or exposed to it
so we're not talking about the antibody
test so i'll just leave it at that those
uh they actually can look very similar
to this or they can be done
uh in a laboratory those are usually
done from blood
and they're looking for an immune
response to the virus so that's one
everything i'm talking about here is
looking for the virus itself not the
immune response to the virus
and so you there's two ways to look for
the virus you can either look for the
genetic code of the virus like the rna
just like the dna of somebody's human
cells
or you can look for the proteins
themselves the antigens
of the prot of the virus so i like to
differentiate them if you were
a a pcr test that looks for rna
in let's say let's say if we made it
against humans it would be looking for
the dna inside of our cells that would
be actually looking for our genetic code
the equivalent to an antigen test is
sort of a
a test that like actually is looking for
our eyes or our nose or physical
features of our body that would
uh delineate okay this is this is uh
michael for example in and so
so you're either looking for this a
sequence or you're looking for a
structure
uh the pcr test that a lot of people
have gotten now and they're done in labs
usually
are looking for the sequence of the
virus which is rna
this test here by a company called
detect
this is one of jonathan rothberg's
companies um
he's the guy who helped create uh modern
day sequencing
and uh all kinds of other things so this
detect device
that's the name of the company this is
actually a rapid rna detection device so
it's almost it's like a pcr-like test
and we could even do it here
it's really it's it's a beautiful test
in my opinion works
exceedingly well it's going to be a
little bit more expensive so i think it
could confirm
could be used as a confirmatory test for
these is there a greater accuracy to it
um yes i would say that there is a
greater accuracy there's also a downfall
though of pcr
and tests that look for rna they
can sometimes detect somebody who is no
longer infectious
so you have the the rna test then you
have these antigen tests
the antigen tests look for structures
but they're generally only going to turn
positive
if people have actively replicating
virus in them
uh and so what happens after an
infection
dissipates you have you've just gone
from having sort of a spike so
if you get infected maybe three days
later the virus gets into exponential
growth
and it can replicate to trillions of
viruses inside the body
your immune system then kind of tackles
it and beats it down to nothing
but what what ends up in the wake of
that you just had a battle you had this
massive battle that just took place
inside your upper respiratory tract
and because of that you've had trillions
and trillions of viruses
go to zero essentially but the rna
is still there it's just these remnants
in the same way that if you go to a
crime
scene and blood was was was sort of
spread all over the crime scene
you're going to find a lot of dna
there's tons of dna there's no people
anymore
but there's a lot of dna there same
thing happens here and so what's
happening with pcr testing
is when people go and use these
exceedingly high
sensitivity pcr tests people will stay
positive for
weeks or months after their infection
has subsided
which has caused a lot of problems in my
opinion it's problems that the cdc and
the fda and doctors don't want to deal
with
but i've tried to publish on it i've
tried to you know
suggest that this is an issue both to
new york times and others and now it's
unfortunately kind of taken on a life of
its own of conspiracy theorists thinking
no
um they call it a case stomach they say
oh you know pcr is
it's detecting people who are no longer
who are right
false positive they're not false
positives they're
they're late positives no longer
transmissible i think the way you
uh like what i saw on rapidtests.org
i really like the distinction between
diagnostic sensitivity and
contagiousness sensitivity
that's it's so
that website is so obvious uh
that it's painful because it's like yeah
that's what we should be talking about
is
how accurately is the test able to
detect
your contagiousness and you have
different plots that show that
actually there's you know um
that antigen tests the tests we're
looking at today like rapid tests
actually really good at detecting
contagiousness absolutely
you